JANET CONRAD: So the
students are also
expected to write papers.
The papers are in the format of
Physical Review Letters, which
I think is a really valuable
thing for a couple of reasons.
First of all, they
actually learn
what's called LaTeX which
is the system of laying out
the papers.
Also, they discover
how incredibly hard
it is to fit what you
have done into four pages.
And I'm pretty strict, they have
to follow the PRL guidelines.
They're not allowed to
go over on their papers.
But they also learn a lot about
what the elements of a paper
are.
Like for example, how do
you write an abstract?
A lot of people have
trouble writing an abstract.
They don't want to give
the answer away early,
and the abstract has
the answer in it.
So they are-- so they're
really bothered by doing that.
They also tend to write
these more like you
would write a book report.
So they have a whole
history section
at the beginning, which is
not what a paper is about.
And so I think it's really
a very valuable experience
for them to learn to write.
I really like teaching writing.
I actually teach a
writing course here
that's a communications
intensive in the major.
So I'm a little bit
unusual this way.
I don't mind grading
all of the papers, which
I think that a lot of people
don't want to teach Junior
Lab because they
don't want to be faced
with grading these papers.
But I think we've got a
very good way of doing it.
We have a rubric,
and the rubric is
what we use to make sure that
we try to stay as even as we
can on all of the students.
All the students
have the rubric also.
It always makes me laugh,
because I hand out the rubric.
I say, this is what
I'm grading you on,
and then the first paper
comes in for the short labs.
And of course, they
haven't read the rubric
and check the paper against it.
And luckily, that paper
doesn't count for anything,
because I always
write across the top,
if you read the rubric you would
find out that you need this,
like a section on your
errors, or things like that.
And I think that the students
really liked that aspect of it.
Another thing that I
do to try to make sure
that all the grading
is even and fair
is that I grade all of the
papers and mark them up.
And also, my TA grades all of
the papers, and marks them up.
And then we get together, and
we compare notes, and make sure
that we've seen the
same things in them,
and decide on what the
grade is going to be.